monsieur le président mes amis au
printemps prochain ce quinquennat
calamiteux va s'achever et le sort de
notre pays reviendra entre les mains du
peuple français
l'élection va se dérouler dans un climat
de des pressions politiques et morales
le pouvoir est en perdition
la société est à cran la france est
menacée sur son propre sol et l'europe
se fissure il ya là comme un parfum
d'époque désaxé le rendez vous 2010 est
doit donc être abordé avec gravité les
primaires constitueront notre premier
test
elles devront démontrer notre capacité à
nous régénérer dans la des macros sedan
la démocratie et à rassembler au-delà de
nos rangs de nous les français attendent
transparence et intégrité pour rétablir
l'ordre et la confiance
l'exemple doit venir d'en haut ils
attendent aussi des idées nouvelles et
ils attendent des convictions affirmées
parce que la france crève de ces
synthèses molles qui ne résolvent rien
notre compétition devra être franc loyal
et une fois le verdict des primaires
annoncé pas une voix ne devra manquer au
vainqueur
de nous les français attendent la vérité
la vérité c'est que notre système est
usée jusqu'à la corde pour abattre le
chômage pour éviter la faillite
il va falloir se retrousser les manches
et il va surtout falloir réformer
radicalement
j'en ai la conviction en nous attaquant
vraiment à nos handicaps nous pouvons
c'est mon objectif visé les 2% de
croissance revenir à l'équilibré de nos
comptes publics atteindre le plein
emploi et d'ici 10 ans être la première
puissance européenne
pour cela il n'y a ni baguette magique
ni sauveur suprême
il faut un projet puisse en donnant à
notre action un mandat impérieux et
incontestable le contrat avec les
électeurs doit être précis quelles
réformes quand comment
pour quel but j'ai sur ces sujets fait
mes propositions
j'ajoute qu'il est temps de revenir à
une lecture ordonné de nos institutions
le président de la république ne doit
être ni normal ni la girouette de
l'actualité quotidienne
il doit tenir le cap du projet et il
doit incarner la continuité française
sous l'impulsion d'eric woerth
notre mouvement s'est doté d'une plate
forme programmatique
je salue cette démarche parce que toutes
les contributions sont utiles dans la
bataille des idées qui va s'engager
maintenant chacun puisera ou non son
inspiration dans ce document
c'est la règle des primaires et c'est la
règle de la vème république qui confère
aux candidats qui va à la rencontre des
français
le devoir d'être au dessus des partis au
coeur de ce qui nous rassemble
je discerne les défis qui nous attendent
l'emploi doit être notre priorité
absolue
nous devrons modernisée de fond en
comble le marché du travail
avec 6 millions de chômeurs et pire
encore avec deux millions de jeunes
français qui ne sont ni à l'école ni
dans un emploi ni dans une formation 2
millions de jeunes français qui sont
dans la rue deux millions de jeunes
français dont l'avenir pour l'immense
majorité d'entre eux c'est le rsa
jusqu'à la fin de leurs jours
et bien pour cela nous devons faire la
révolution du bon sens et si nous ne
faisons pas cette révolution du bon sens
celle qui consiste à appliquer les
mesures et les règles qui ont permis à
toutes les autres grandes puissances
occidentales d'atteindre le plein emploi
alors je vous le dis un jour la révolte
sociale balayera tout
contre le chômage nous avons essayé
beaucoup de choses sauf une la valeur
première de notre devise
la liberté aux mots aux mots de liberté
françois hollande se dresse en défenseur
de notre modèle social et il nous fait
son sermon moi ou le chaos
mais monsieur hollande le chaos c'est
vous
la cour des comptes des masques ses
mensonges toujours plus de dépenses
publiques
toujours plus de dettes est malgré tout
toujours peu de croissance
toujours plus de chômage est toujours
moins d'autorité de l'étang je n'écoute
pas les fossoyeurs de la france et leurs
intimidations qui ont pour but de ne
rien changer au demeurant je ne suis pas
seul les agriculteurs les médecins les
artisans les auto-entrepreneurs les
jeunes qui rêvent de réussite
eux ils n'ont pas peur de la liberté ils
n'ont en réalité que rage pour ce
conservatisme qui les anglais nous ne
sommes pas socialiste alors laissons
souffler le vent de la liberté dans les
voiles de la france
laliberté doser la liberté de travail et
la liberté de négocier dans les
entreprises
la liberté de se prononcer par
référendum la liberté de pouvoir grimper
les échelons de la réussite sociale sans
être taxé à chaque palier
en chaque être humain il existe une
force créatrice une fierté alors liberté
à la liberté mais aussi mes amis unité
nationale parce que nous ne représentons
que 1% de la population mondiale
alors si nous ne sommes pas convaincus
que notre rassemblement fait notre forte
autant rendre les armes
aujourd'hui notre république est blessé
elle l'est lorsque l'un des nôtres
poignardent un couple de policiers au
nom de je ne sais quel versets
sataniques
elle est lorsqu à verdun le silence de
la mémoire est rompu par des
organisateurs de kermesse et puis
et puis est on vraiment citoyens
français
lorsqu'on sa cage un hôpital pour
enfants malades
la question de l'unité nationale ne se
réduit pas à celle de l'immigration
parce que notre patrie l affaire de tous
assez de contrition assez de remords
assez d'égoïste la france doit être aimé
et chacun doit se demander ce qu'il peut
faire pour elle avant de se demander ce
qu'elle fera pour lui
le demandent nous devrons renforcer les
piliers de notre république
l'état doit être commandé avec autorité
et avec prestige avec l'appui de ses
fonctionnaires qui doivent être
respectées et performant cela exige le
retour aux 39 heures des perspectives de
carrière plus motivante et des moyens
pour agir plutôt que pour financer des
effectifs pléthoriques et rembourser les
déficits qui vont avec
la sécurité doit être partout et pour
tous avec des forces de l'ordre
moderniser et une justice ferme et
rapide
mes amis notre retour aux affaires ce
sera la fin de l'ère taubira
la famille premier cercle de nos
solidarités devra être protégé nous la
considérons comme une valeur pas comme
une variable budgétaire et encore moins
comme le laboratoire de toutes les
expériences sociétale
nous avons combattu la loi taubira
on ne peut pas maintenant dire ce que
nous avons combattu au nom de la morale
et au nom des valeurs essentielles
c'est très bien on n'y changera rien
j'ai toujours dit qu'il fallait réécrire
le droit de la filiation pour inscrire
dans le code civil
un principe un enfant est toujours né
d'un père et d'une mère
et puis
et puis il ya l'école qui transmet les
savoirs fondamentaux autour desquels
nous devons concentrer les efforts
plutôt que de multiplier les activités
périphériques l'école qui doit préparer
à un métier avec une valorisation
massive de l'alternance et avec la
création d'une grande ensemble centrale
d'éducation professionnelle qu'il faut
soustraire à la gestion directe de
l'éducation nationale pour le placer
sous la gestion des régions et des
branches professionnelles
l'école qui doit être l'école de la
république
et s'il faut des symboles pour le
rappeler alors instaurons l'uniforme
scolaire
l'unité nationale commande une
immigration strictement contrôlés choisi
par quotas obéissant aux devoirs pour
les étrangers de se plier à une langue à
des moeurs et à 2000 ans d'histoire
c'est une question d'unité nationale
mais c'est aussi une question de
courtoisie
parce que le dernier arrivé dans la
demeure ne doit pas se croire m chez les
autres
la laïcité est notre digue contre
l'obscurantisme
je suis catholique et je défends la
liberté religieuse et je n'accepterai
jamais que l'état empêche d'exercer
cette liberté religieuse mais la
religion n'est pas un projet de société
ce que la république a autrefois exigé
de l'église catholiques des protestants
et des juifs
elle a le droit de l'exiger aujourd'hui
du culte musulman
son financement doit être transparent
ces imams doivent être irréprochables et
pour cela contrôler les salafistes et
les frères musulmans qui professent des
valeurs qui sont contraires à l'essence
même de la république doivent être
interdits sur le territoire national
les pouvoirs publics sont en droit de
contrôler tout cela aux côtés de l'état
nos concitoyens musulmans doivent se
soulever contre ceux qui
instrumentalisent leur foi il faut faire
le ménage
quelles que soient nos croyances nous
sommes tous français et c'est ensemble
que nous pourrons vaincre si certains ne
savent pas ce qu'est l'identité
française
les terroristes eux le savent la liberté
l'égalité des sexes la fraternité entre
tous le droit de croire ou de ne pas
croire le droit de rire le droit de
s'aimer le droit de voter pour les
fanatiques c'est tout cela qui doit être
mitraillés
nous avons dans notre code civil et dans
notre code pénal l'arsenal pour y poster
avant de multiplier les lois utilisons
cet arsenal sans état d'âme et notamment
les dispositions qui permettent de
priver de liberté
ceux qui entretiennent une relation avec
l'ennemi que nous combattons en irak en
syrie et au sel
à situation exceptionnelle il faut une
justice exceptionnel il nous faudra
beaucoup d'alliés pour éteindre
l'incendié qui traverse le monde et
parmi ses alliés il y à la russie que
l'on continue à sanctionner alors que
c'est l'état islamique que nous devons
terrassé ensemble plus nous attendons
plus les métastases du totalitarisme
islamique s'étendre plus les réfugiés
près de la mer et plus les chrétiens
d'orient sont décimés ces chrétiens du
levant je les soutiens et je suis allé
les voir à plusieurs reprises et j'y
suis allé parce que si nous français
nous ne sommes pas à leurs côtés alors
personne ne prendra leur défense dans le
monde
notre politique étrangère a multiplié
les erreurs il est temps de lui imprimer
une vision qui ne soit pas celle de
saint germain des prés et pas
nécessairement celles de washington qui
ne fut pas d'une grande clairvoyance ces
dernières années dans ce monde chaotique
est ce que l'europe et notre bouclier et
notre tremplin
non le break 6 2 vient de lui asséner un
coup qui peut être mortelle si nous ne
savons pas réagir je n'ai pas été
surpris par ce vote de rejet en 1992
philippe séguin on pressentait déjà les
risques quand on oublie les nations
alors les nations se venge pour autant
je refuse cette chasse à l'homme qui
agite tous ces démagogues qui préfèrent
incriminé bruxelles de tous nos maux
plutôt que de les résoudre
ceux qui cherchent des boucs émissaires
ceux qui se cherchent des excuses pour
moi la souveraineté ne rime pas avec la
lâcheté
l'urgence c'est de régler le cas
britannique le divorce doit être serein
mais il doit être rapide les anglais
sortent mais ne devienne pas pour autant
des adversaires ni complaisance ni
hostilité comme l'a fort bien dit bruno
retailleau
il serait étrange que l'on demande des
visas aux britanniques et qu'on refuse
d'en demander demain aux turcs
l'élargissement a rendu caduque le rêve
illusoire du fédéralisme et il a
congestionné le fonctionnement
communautaire des années 80 il faut donc
revoir les institutions européennes
mais ne tirons pas de plans sur la
comète on ne joue pas avec l'avenir de
notre continent à pile ou face
c'est la différence entre les hommes
d'état et les démagogues margaret
thatcher n'avait pas de mots assez durs
contre l'europe mais elle n'a jamais
fait quitter son pays de l'union
européenne monsieur cameron restera
qu'ils le veuillent ou non dans
l'histoire celui qui aura fait quitter
la grande bretagne de l'union européenne
et de la même façon et de la même façon
le général de gaulle n'était pas tendre
avec l'europe mais c'est lui qui l'a
fait entrer les qui a fait entrer la
france dans le marché commun françois
hollande n'a pas de mots assez forts
pour parler de l'europe et de la
nécessité de la construire
mais il restera dans l'histoire celui
qui a fait en sorte par sa faiblesse par
son impuissance que l'europe connaissent
la crise la plus grave depuis la
création du marché commun
dans l'immédiat il faut recentrer
l'europe sur des priorités stratégiques
et renvoyé tout le reste a la compétence
des états la première de ses priorités
c'est l'indépendance économique de
l'europe dans la mondialisation assez
d'angélisme
nous n'avons ni obligation de signer un
traité transatlantique déséquilibrée ni
à subir la domination économique
asiatique notre indépendance est aussi
mise à mal par la tutelle qu'imposent
les états unis aux entreprises
européennes soumises à la législation
intérieure américaine au seul prétexte
qu'elle utilise le dollar
la seule façon de résister à cette
emprise
c'est de faire de l'euro une vraie
monnaie internationale
une vraie monnaie de réserve et de
règlements et pour cela la zone euro
doit se donner les moyens d'être l'une
des plus performantes du monde il faut
la doter d'un gouvernement économique
piloté par les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement d'un secrétaire général et
d'un contrôle par les parlements
nationaux
il faut un calendrier d'harmonisation de
la fiscalité des entreprises
il faut favoriser nos géants industriels
et il faut apurer nos dettes
la seconde priorité c'est la sécurité
européenne
l'europe est menacée de disparaître si
elle n'est pas une europe qui protège
nous avons besoin d'un nouveau schengen
avec un vrai corps de gardes-frontières
et de garde-côtes avec une coopération
sans faille entre les services de
sécurité et dans la tente
la surveillance de nos propres
frontières doit être entendue depuis la
fin de la guerre froide
l'europe de la défense n'a rien fait
pour prendre son destin en main
elle continue de s'en remettre aux états
unis or ce protectorat est devenu
illusoire si l'europe n'est pas capable
de se défendre alors mérite t'elle
vraiment d'exister dans le respect de la
souveraineté des nations
nous devons constituer une alliance de
défense européenne qui permette un juste
partage des charges et je voudrais
puisque je cite la défense rendre devant
vous hommage à ces soldats français qui
aux avant postes
de l'europe défendre les valeurs qui
sont les nôtres il les défendent au prix
de leur vie ils les défendent pour nous
mais les défendent aussi pour le peuple
allemand et pour les autres peuples
européens qui doivent participer à
l'effort de sécurité du continent
troisième priorité je veux parler
éducation et culture parce que la crise
actuelle c'est celle de la conscience
européenne
on a fait erasmus on à homogénéiser les
diplômes universitaires on a relié
laboratoire mais ce qu'on a fait assez
pour développer ce sentiment
d'appartenir à une civilisation
singulière et brillante la philosophie
antique l'esprit du christianisme l'état
de droit le goût des arts et des
sciences légales dignité des êtres la
liberté de penser de voter c'est tout
cela qui forgent l'âme de l'europe et
c'est pour défendre ce patrimoine que
nous sommes ensemble pas pour harmoniser
la taille des essuie-glaces mes amis
nous avons le devoir de nous poser la
question dans dix ans l'union européenne
existera t elle encore l'asie est en
train de devenir l'épicentre économique
du monde
l'ancien domination occidentale et
chaque jour disputée par des milliards
d'habitants qui sont convaincus que le
progrès est à portée de leurs mains nous
ne savons même plus ce que signifie le
mot progrès pire le mot progrès nous
angoisse de l'autre côté de la
méditerranée des foules de déshérités
sont prêtes à tout tenter pour rejoindre
nos côtes
est-ce que nous allons finir comme un
vaste hotspot débordé par la misère du
monde et la pauvreté d'ici
et puis nous voici menacés par ce
totalitarisme islamique qui rêve
d'arracher nos racines et bien face à
tous ces défis nous devons être sûrs de
ce que nous sommes
je suis fier d'être français et je me
sens européen mais il suffit pas de dire
vive l'europe pour que l'europe vive
après les deux grandes guerres nous
avons marché main dans la main nous
avons déposé des gerbes
nous avons multiplié les accolades
l'europe a réussi à réconcilier les
survivants il faut maintenant la
réconcilier avec l'avenir le départ des
britanniques ne confère une nouvelle
responsabilité
jusqu'à présent nous figurions parmi les
trois grandes nations de l'union
européenne dorénavant la france est avec
l'allemagne
l'autre puissance européenne de notre
courage de notre rayonnement dépend le
sort de notre continent
mais nous ne devons pas faire preuve de
forfanterie
l'europe c'est un lieu de pouvoir
c'est un lieu où les nations fortes
impriment leur rythme aux autres
lorsque la france est faible elle subit
l'europe lorsqu'elle est puissante
elle l'a conduit françois hollande et sa
politique ont dégradé la force
d'entraînement de notre pays est bien le
prochain président de la république aura
la charge de prendre les choses en main
le général de gaulle disait l'essentiel
pour jouer un rôle au delà de ses
frontières
c'est d'exister par soi même chez soi
et bien pour moi pour vous mes
compagnons il est grand temps de
redonner à la france le pouvoir d'être
forte chez elle afin d'être grande pour
l'europe